welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we're going to talk
about the emission and the absorption of
photons so you can think about a
scenario where you have an atom
um which
emits the photon like in this picture
here
and you create a new atom which we call
you know the atom prime
in the absorption process you have a
collision between a photon and the atom
and you make a new atom
um again indicated by a prime
so i want you to actually work this out
um in in two activities the first one is
on absorption
so here we have a stationary particle
the atom with with a mass m0 and it's
struck by a photon right this scenario
here
and the photon has an energy q and
becomes and and there's a new particle
coming out with a rest mass m not prime
and a recoiling velocity as
has to have some sort of momentum v and
so the question is how can we now find
the mass of this new particle and the
velocity so please stop the video and
try to work this out
so the way to work this out
is by
um writing energy and momentum equation
you can do this just with a four vector
here even so we're not performing any
launch transformation in this part you
can just write down the four vector and
you know this needs to be conserved
energy and momentum need to be conserved
in this collision
all right so we have the mass
of this initial particle at rest
so the energy is m naught c square the
energy of the photon is q the momentum
of the photon is q over c
and so then the final
particle the outcoming new particle has
its own mass but it has a boost so the
total energy is m naught
prime gamma using the velocity of this
of this particle c square and the
momentum
is
m naught prime gamma times b
so that's after the collision and so
then you can use the energy relation in
order to get to the mass
this is a function of the velocity here
and you can get the velocity
um by looking at the momentum so you
basically solve for this v or v over c
in this case and then if you want you
can add this back in here in order to
get the mass
as just as a function of the energy of
the mass of the initial particle and the
energy of the proton
all right
the second example now is the emission
so here we have a stationary atom with a
rest mass m naught and it emits the
photon with energy q and it becomes the
new atom with rest mass m naught
prime and recalling with the velocity
now given the two masses what is the
energy of the photon
q
so we set this up in the same way as
before now we start with this particle
at rest
and that then
the energy is m naught c squared
momentum is zero
and that's you know equal to the energy
and momentum of the new particle and the
photon
in the very same way as we set this up
before
so now what we want to do here is use
our
invariance of the four vector
using the energy and momentum relation
so the mass
of this new particle times c square
squared is equal to the energy squared
the energy squared now you just bring
this over here it's m naught c squared
minus q squared and then the momentum is
simply
of this new particle is simply q square
this you can now solve for q
and you find this relation here
okay so that's the energy of the
of the outgoing filter
um if you now define q naught as the
difference in masses or the difference
times
of the masses times c square
then you can write the the energy of the
photon as q naught
times one minus q naught over two m c
square and that's always smaller than
the difference in masses
all right so if we now analyze this and
look at this some more and try to
understand what it means what we find is
that the emission and the absorption
they only occur at a very precise value
of of the energy of the photon
it also means that an emitted photon can
only be reabsorbed if the particles are
moving with just the right velocity
right so if you if you're an atom and
the photon goes out and your neighboring
atom is just sitting there next to you
at rest as you've had rest before is not
able to reabsorb the fulton
all right so we learned just by using
special relativity quite a bit about the
physics involved in absorption and
emission of photons
you